like people in the comments right even
when Cheno put up a post like these guys
got to make their comments limited when
you say Channel who you talking about
Maino yeah mano's Channel you know
exactly who he is the world I love Mano
man I was just in uh Emmanuel doesn't
love you you love him he doesn't love
you that's right or solid he's a good
guy what is he done good I mean
I can't speak to you help anybody in
this community but that's how you judge
a man you judging me as character by
their actions but you and may not have
great records together you guys you've
done favors for him and I've and I've
done records and I've carried I mean it
was on your album too no he's on it he
wasn't on New York City [__] no no what
was the record oh no I'm thinking of
Prodigy I'm thinking of The Prodigy when
I do albums I'm meticulous with them
[__] I don't know I'm thinking of that
yeah
people who I admire on New York City the
album not just whoever is you never
admired Mano ever
because he was from from Brooklyn right
and he was coming up I'ma always support
I'm I show love right you know what I'm
saying always I show love that's how I'm
always show love so I bought this album
when he came out it was trash you know
what I'm saying that was trash though
well there's only one that I was the
first album was great his first time
Kevin come on no no that I'm on Atlanta
with fire here we go here we gonna go
with the cats
the first album was great right his
debut album on Atlantic was crazy the
first album was great it was great is it
better than hit a record on there called
Soldier I bet you was it it's not better
than and I'm not even gonna say classic
like outcasts and [__] like that since
you seen the albums album
no I think this is one of the greatest
albums ever okay you don't got a bunch
of albums over here
um no I got some here
it's better than this but I'm not going
I'm not I think it's better by end he
could never do nothing better than I
think Manos he got him is better than
that album from nas his first album
because he's put out other albums
through Empire and [__] oh what bro his
first album was hard oh we got seriously
looking to you uh we gotta look nah bro
you the only person saying it that's not
true you I'm telling you who you and him
now mano's album is hard bro his first
album it's good take it so people get in
the comments yeah tell me your comments
and especially from New York my bandana
Soldier he has some [__] on that person
all right so if you call his album great
what would you call New York City album
if you had to rate them from one attack
I think it's a better album
you know I'm a huge fan of New York City
I think that's your best album I want to
see
it you think I win yet then um that's
more of everything but what
when you say great album if on a scale
of one to ten if New York City the album
was a 10 or whatever you want to call it
what would that album be because we got
a deal in facts here we're gonna bring
the facto show to my God blue they kept
[__] and we only our opinion is always
based on fact okay so what would be good
get rich or die trying to be a 10 yeah
absolutely a lot of things I won't
I'm gonna say like a 9.8 I'm I'm okay
get rich or die trying I got a personal
thing with like 50 Cent Get Rich or Die
Trying is a 10.
New York City the album for me is like a
like a Hard Eight okay and I think man
was almost like a seven and a half
seven are you sitting me his first album
is fire bro let's go to Pitchfork
because Pitchfork actually just worked
they give people zeros that's a bunch of
[__] Williamsburg [__] weenies in
tight pants [__] rating albums
[__] pictures oh you say is a great
album because they had it right out on
their lights is it lyricism
it was a concept album
voice records
it was a good concept it started off
with him getting freed from jail I like
the album oh you want me to that's it no
no it's objective no I just want to know
why your opinion is like that because I
want it because people have opinions
but I just I was saying like your
opinion like I think it was I'll tell
you why I Love YG album his first album
all my crazy Life's a classic for sure
it's what I'm trying to say it's about a
that's like a 9.2 when we say greats and
Classics now most people would tell you
New York City album is a classical
amazing what I'll do is classical new
pop that's what most people would tell
you it was the classics now
I'm not gonna toot my own on my new [__]
but I've never heard nobody say his [__]
was a classic and we got to be careful
with the titles that we give the things
well I didn't say I didn't say classic I
said it was a great album though
what I mean great album so we have bad
albums good albums great albums
something else and then Classics or yeah
all right so it's made
it's a great album yeah we got two
levels above it it's made two levels
above it two levels below I just want
with hip-hop is too much gray areas like
when you see I mean it's all objective
it's all winning hip-hop Awards this is
also objective to like what I'm serious
people there's people who lit who love
playboi carti I don't agree with them
well but but that's the thing it's
subjective we have if we have a uh if we
have a grading system and a formula
there's no formula because everyone's
grading system and formula is different
that's what I'm trying to say that's
what we need if we have a great somebody
some people might say like I might be
like yo
Augustine is my favorite player I know
Jordan is better but Iverson is my goat
you know what I'm saying exactly but I
can say why okay Jordan is better for
these reasons you know what I'm saying
no I'm not the same way I feel about
like a lot of rap [__] I could be like
Pusha T is in my top five or maybe my
top like eight push it to you probably
top
see now you saying overall if I'm
talking about drugs
overall my personal favorites Pusha T's
in my top ten yeah hands down
if you were to have me put together like
the not bootleg cab 10 push is not in
the top ten okay so you mean but I'm
putting him high as [__] on my [__]
right I don't know I feel you that's why
he's right there you know what I'm
saying I got Tupac up there I just got
into a [__] argument with Jim Jones
that went viral over him saying Pusha T
wasn't top 50 I was like you're [__]
crazy yeah I heard it but I heard about
him saying it on like top 50 that's
crazy it's a wild wild statement
um no so
his name is chano when I was I just came
from the Vegas fight with uh uh Javonte
Davis and Ryan Garcia I'm on the floor
seats you know what I said there's no
haters it cost money to be a hater or an
enemy or Optima okay I'm on floor seats
I'm walking around the whole [__] I walk
the yard people yelling say no say no yo
Troy Ave keep doing what the [__] you
doing everybody celebrities I love what
you I'm introducing myself to people who
I didn't think know me yo man help me
understand like that I'll [__] with you
what's the origin of the of the of the
Maino thing they could go watch
documentaries so listen I saw a video
where you know where you were on your
Instagram
where you were claiming that mayna was
wearing the same Cuban Link I didn't
claim that he he he claimed the people
claim that the people claim that the
people winning his comments and said he
had a chain that he that he But but so
it was faith that he pooped but to me
when you're pointing out just the like
Cuban Link what
that's like it's a little isn't the
Cuban language no no but there were some
some of the things you pointed out that
were like yo look you still got the same
Cube I never said anything that's the
people yeah but like to say to say like
one Cuban Link and another Cuban Link
are the same but we're not talking about
he's talking about the Jesus Piece
action whatever he pulled out in the
back of that minute right me back but
that's different from I saw a post of
yours where you were talking about
look he's wearing that same chain link
without the piece I've never I've I've
never said that that's a fact I know
what I say I've never said that there's
a documentary a short that shows
everything who's putting out who's
putting it together these are you
putting together these dogs the people
man the people I got de facto Show
podcast even the title I did with me as
Batman everybody knows Batman is Bruce
Wayne he has beautiful women he lives
luxurious houses jobs nice cars and
there's a bunch of bottom feet of haters
the penguin Bane Joker that's where all
these people are so let me ask you this
Troy because if people put that together
I said in a factory show I feel like
Batman hey yo facto show real one
viewers I need y'all make me a couple
like that with all these haters and he
did it